[Musique]
madame dati c'est moi qui parle et en
l'occurrence même quand j'étais prof à
sarcelles les élèves se taisait donc
vous allez faire pareil
et donc
et donc est donc en l'occurrence est
donc en l'occurrence si le carreau
n'avait pas été réparée c'est
précisément parce que la procédure
d'assurance était trop complexe ans je
vais terminer non non non non vous
attendez la fin de l'intervention de ian
brossât non mal à vous attendez la
faveur de l'intervention de ian brossât
que vous avez essayé de perturber mais
vous me permettrez or fera ça fait votre
rappel au règlement après
yann continue yann continue
eh bien je vais vous répondre madame
dati ça veut dire que n'importe qui ça
veut dire que n'importe qui vous
permettez qu'on vous répondent vous
permettez qu'on vous répondent ou pas il
ya mes bras ça termine son intervention
non il termine son intervention pas dans
votre état non vous n'êtes pas
d'interrompre cette séance madame dati
il y a des gens qui vous répondent donc
il ya un an après le rappel au règlement
c'est après l'intervention yann ian
brossât termine son intervention
ian brossât termine son intervention
ça veut dire une chose simple
ne laissez pas passer je maintiens je
maintiens que n'importe qui c'est que
quand quelqu'un parle on le laisse finir
rappel au règlement veut que la personne
qui est en train d'intervenir termine
son intervention il y aura le rappelle
un terreau règlement après rap allez-y